now I want to know does anyone here know
what an alpha Widow is let's let's ask
the girls first I literally have never
heard of this terminology okay
um so I'm guessing it's something to do
with super strong women but that's as
far as I'll take it okay what about you
guys yeah no I've not actually heard of
that at all
I have no clue and I'm scared to
discover what it's going to be about
okay never heard of it
okay what about I know you guys um
watched a little bit in the recipe
you've heard of it no I know both words
I don't know the it together though
so a woman usually with average sexual
market value who sleeps with a high
sexual market value male the alpha male
who does not wish to have a long-term
relationship with that woman the woman
views the alpha male as Superior to most
if not all of the other men's pursuing
her and so the woman continues to lust
after the alpha male she cannot have
sacrificing future long-term
relationships with lower smv men making
her a widow in a sense
to the original alpha male
wow I feel like so many women are
probably that
that's a fact yeah does that resonate
with any of you I feel targeted
why is there is there like is there an
ax you that you haven't gotten over do
you think about a lot
not to put you on the spot you don't
have to answer if you don't want to not
gotten over but um that's so weird that
is so so weird that you've actually said
that um
I'm actually currently in a situation
where
not in a relationship because I am
single
um
and I feel like I I say blocking my
blessings because I'm spending so much
time focused on that person but they
don't want
a relationship as such
would you say that's a common situation
that girls find themselves in
yeah yes yeah would you say like it
doesn't have to be with you but like
with your friends as well
so an interesting stat
um that I learned when I started getting
into like red pill stuff is that a
hundred percent of women want 20 of men
so the reason that women think men are
trash is because we're all sleeping with
the same ones
[Laughter]
25 is low yeah that's high I think
actually yeah I mean if you look at
dating app data it's smaller like some
people think it's five ten percent
because okay let's say you want a guy
that's over six foot that's like a
comment I'm not saying you guys do but
that's a common thing that I've heard of
that's only 15 percent of men or over
six foot oh wow so and let's say you
want him to be good looking like let's
say half a people are ugly half of
people are good looking just on that on
average right that's that's 7.5 percent
let's say he has to make a certain
amount of money that's three that's
three percent so it becomes a smaller
and smaller percentage and it's funny
because when I tell girls this stuff I
see looks of shock but when I tell men
this they're like oh we been knew this
yeah that's in fact it's a fact you
always really think that they can all
bag that same guy but
it's just such a small percentage of men
so it's not really it's not logical to
even think like that it's quite
unrealistic exactly so very tall
so I have I have a story
okay so man's dying wife
asks me to laugh so bad man's dying wife
asks if she can have sex with her ex
Just One Last Time
any spouse would want to provide the
love and care for their partner within
their dying months and days but one man
has shared how his dying wife has ex has
expressed a specific wish to sleep with
an ex posting to the relationship advice
subreddit the husband gave insight into
his wife's condition and how the
conversation of her controversial dying
wish went down as he has no one I can
tell to begin with he explained how he
was destroyed that his wife of 10 years
had a terminal disease and expected to
live at least nine months I I don't
remember life without her and I don't
know what I'm gonna do when she's gone I
have been doing my best to make the last
days of her life good and Grant whatever
wish I can he said
on her deteriorating condition he added
the doctor said that she was likely to
need a wheelchair and need a wheelchair
in four or five months and by month
eight she'll be bedridden for the last
few weeks that's if she doesn't decline
faster after he provided the contacts
the husband got to the quirks of the
problem he said recently she sat me down
and told me that one of the last things
she wanted to do was have sex with a
previous partner of hers
I of course was shocked and when I asked
why the F she wants that her response
was pretty brutal as she revealed
she basically so basically she thinks
that her most physically compatible
sexual lover was him she gave him a
whole monologue about how sex sometimes
is just physical and how emotionally
fulfilling sex is with me but it was
[ __ ] to get to the point so now I'm
left with deny my why my dying wife a
wish for my own ego or let her go [ __ ]
another man that she feels was better
honestly I'm so pissed off and betrayed
that she asked this of me I feel like
I'm put in a position where I have to
say yes because she's dying I don't know
what to say but I don't know if that's
right I'm so hurt by that sex with an ex
was apparently so good that she needed
to do it once before she dies I hate
everything about this I'm not sure what
to do
after explaining the situation the
husband's post was met with a lot of
responses some took the story to Twitter
where people began to share their
thoughts and where people were divided
you've got to figure out what type of
man that is a man that has gone into a
situation knowing full well he probably
wasn't the number one choice but he is
probably catering to all her needs so
her feeling comfortable enough to have
that conversation with him is a kind of
reflection on their relationship she
don't respect him from jump yeah yeah
and so for her to have come up to him
and gone yeah look the sex with you
ain't it I'm trying to find out from the
guy I really wanted you cool with that
that's mad
he probably offered a better package so
he was like that husband material and
obviously have to make sacrifices at
times and maybe she sacrificed the sex
to have the perfect relationship that
maybe the financial support maybe the
emotional support because we all know
sometimes when it comes down to sex it
can be great but the person's not that
good yeah like as a person so maybe that
was why she was with him and you know
one last goodbye nah man you can't pick
and choose you can't in it she's gone
sacrificed if she's asking for it in the
last nine months of life so what I got
to do with you you know why I got to
deal with you that is but then you
wouldn't you wouldn't Nick the whole
package and then at the last nine months
she wants to [ __ ] die but then can I
play Devil's Advocate what if we can
just say like sex is just physical cool
right I know we're going to talk about
like intimacy and emotional if you let
me if you're letting me before these
nine months you do me do my thing you
got nine months gone then but you're not
gonna let me do my thing so it's like
for now it's different in it for men for
men it's just physical because when men
can just sold you on though
why are you shaking your head for men
it's it's like not emotional it's just
physical yeah women can be exactly the
same less women than that person I have
been that person where I have gone and
done what I felt like I needed to do and
had no emotional connection I just
wanted to have that one experience or
why didn't you say by and large though
women are attach more emotion to sex
because we release a hormone that men
don't during sex yeah so there's like a
bonding hormone and it's the more
Partners you sleep with the less you
release that hormone so a lot of times
like when girls say that it's like they
they had a lot of Partners so they don't
release the hormone as much anymore yeah
that's probably where I'm at wow oh you
didn't know that that makes so much
sense yeah because particularly like
very
I don't like have loads of sexual
partners so I'm really careful because I
know I can get emotionally attached so I
prefer to do it in a relationship or get
pissed off if I'm in a situationship
it's happening it's not worked out so
that makes so much sense I didn't know
that well and that's why like
um a lot of times they say a girl can't
fall in love unless she's had the best
sex of her life because it's like that's
how girls bond is like through when they
that makes yeah when they orgasm yeah
um it's different about men on the other
hand they can't have sex with a hole in
the wall and they'll be fine
I feel like a lot of men though I mean
majority of men yeah like I've asked
this question like if you ever slept
with a girl that you wouldn't be seen in
public with 100 all men have done that
yeah 99 of men but that's kind of the
problem with the sexual Marketplace
because essentially like the small
percentage of men are sleeping with all
the girls and so then like girls think
they're on that level but they're not
yeah because like your level is what you
can get to take you out in public
basically okay yeah that's a fact
there's a lot of girls men wouldn't be
seen with that they [ __ ] oh can I say
that wait no
there's a lot of girls that men wouldn't
be seen with in public that they've had
sexual relations with yeah yeah yeah I
mean it's similar to when you have a
date you have a blind date and he turns
up and you're like oh dear I can't go
anywhere that I was planning on going
and now I need to hide so it's it works
both ways but maybe the sex doesn't
happen that's a bit different yeah
and you'll get the food and you're gonna
[ __ ] off and not see that guys that guy
is suffering
I mean this whole situation is kind of
unfortunate
because I think I've actually been that
person oh so there was like um I did
this like American Girl She was Cali
like light blue hair really into like
every sexual thing you could imagine was
as like left crazy liberals you can
identify as like a man but but it's
heterosexual but also he's a lesbian she
had it with the tags and we're messing
around and one of her last guy was like
when we hung out she really liked this
guy like she really cherished the
friendship and she tells me that yeah we
spent a night together and it was trash
like like the deal was trash but like
the love between them like she really
cherishes this guy
um so yeah and I was there like I mean
you know
the provider you're fine
it's unfortunate I just think I find it
really bizarre that a woman or a man can
have sex with someone that they
I don't know I'm not attracted to like
that or
they don't feel something for
I find that really bizarre well it's
it's because it's got to have there's
got to be connection if I've got no
connection with you there's no way it's
gonna work it's just right but we're
thinking from a woman's point of view so
from from like the typical woman's point
of view like we're thinking how on Earth
could you have sex with someone like
guys will have sex with girls they hate
yeah yeah you know it is though okay
yeah I can't speak for every guy but
it's that it's that post you know I
don't know what's what's yeah but the
exactly post not Clarity listen I'm not
gonna lie oh [ __ ] I spoke to like Amanda
man and I've asked them like questions
like that like have you ever I think a
lot of guys do is after the mission
complete yeah they're like oh like I
should have aborted this Mission
beforehand but you don't see that
reality until like only a very
disciplined and aware man and very like
yeah it's not the I'll feel that
majority can definitely sleep with
someone and not feel nothing for them
but I ain't here for a relationship
yeah I have a lot of mates that say oh
yeah I slept with this girl but I don't
fence here I love I don't I don't like
her and I'm like what what why did you
slap me there in the first place like
there is no way why'd she sleep with her
you know because most girls you kind of
know what a guy's after like a lot of
times girls we pretend we don't know we
kind of like act like because we want
the attention from the guy but we know
we know which guy's actually like us and
which ones are just oh yeah we're just
pretend doing sometimes and say no I
don't know I don't know yeah but yeah as
a woman you you already know you already
know if it's gonna be a prick or not
yeah straight away yeah but but it's
crazy though because a lot of times the
same girls will cry later and say men
are trash but how can you say men are
trash when you picked them yeah
don't cry now I don't agree with that
yeah
why not though because
men lie yeah
it's not personal no no no no I agree
good okay so people aren't clear
people aren't fully honest yeah right so
someone will tell you everything you
want to hear in order to get what they
want 100 right and then when they get
what they want they might think oh you
know what I like that I want that again
I'm gonna keep lying they're gonna get
that again
so now the female is sitting there
thinking oh this guy's amazing but it's
all based on a lie as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible